another day another tidy explanation of
what seems to be a gaping plot hold an
Avengers endgame as ever major spoilers
ahead the flicks directors Joe and
Anthony Russo addressed a bunch of
burning questions during a recent Q&A in
China among these why couldn't Doctor
Strange simply say portal furnaces
Infinity Gauntlet turned into another
dimension now this is an excellent
question for one simple reason
those yellow sparklies have proven to be
quite effective as a weapon in Avengers
infinity ward during Wong's battle with
coal obsidian
the gigantic beast had his arm severed
by one of the portals why couldn't
Doctor Strange have done the exact same
thing to Thanos during endgames
climactic clash
he also Rousseau's his response
according to we got discovered phallus
his skin is almost impenetrable we don't
know whether dr. strange had the
capability to do it if he failed to cut
it on time Thanos would still be able to
do the snap dr. strange realized this
issue during his millions of test runs
that last part actually seems like an
extremely strong explanation you could
rely on that as an answer to just about
any variation of the same question and
it kind of defies second guessing
strange didn't attempt to lay the old
magic alarm chopping Trek on Thanos
because he knew it wouldn't work in fact
he had already seen every possible
strategy for defeating the mad Titan 14
million 605 of them to be exact drawing
his future viewing fest on Titan in
infinity war and he alone was privy to
the one strategy out of all those that
would work in order for Thanos to
ultimately fail he would first have to
succeed strange would have known that
there was no way to stop him from
gathering all of the Infinity stones and
no way to prevent the decimation from
happening hence there's one condition
for voluntarily offering up the time
stone to Thanos that Tony Stark's life
be spared
without Stark around to perfect the
technology for time travel The Avengers
strategy of deploying teams to various
points in time to preemptively acquire
all the stones wouldn't have been
possible strange new as well the only
Stark who designed the Infinity Gauntlet
2.0 would have the wherewithal to pull
the old gauntlet switcheroo on Thanos at
the crucial moment that's the beauty of
the Russo's his explanation it's
basically bulletproof and it applies to
literally any alternate scenario why
didn't our heroes attend the same trick
they had on Titan using mantas to
distract Thanos until someone could be
gankers going it off
well because Strange knew it wouldn't
work why didn't Stark uses nearly all
powerful nanotech to build a fan Oh size
suit of armor that
trap the mad Titan and fly min to the
Sun because strange knew it wouldn't
work
why didn't Captain Marvel just crater
his big purple butt ask dr. strange
he'll tell you it's because he knew it
wouldn't work the more you think about
strangers viewings of those millions of
possible outcomes the more mind-blowing
it becomes as a storytelling device or a
convenient little storytelling cheats
depending on your point of view on the
surface the line seems to illustrate for
the audience just how stack the odds
were against our heroes but more than
that it also allows Marvel to dismiss
any and all questions beginning with why
couldn't they have just in one fell
swoop
at any rate the Russos have been busy
shutting down all the full of plot holes
talked since then the game's release and
their explanations should only motivate
you to take him repeat viewings at your
earliest convenience to see if they
check out armed with their insider
knowledge you'll probably want to check
it out another time or two while it's
still in theaters check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about Avengers endgame are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]